Un mois après, je passe un court séjour à la maison en Caroline du nord.
Le dernier soir, j'accours dans la chambre de Deah,
impatiente de savoir comment il se sent, comme jeune marié.
Avec un grand sourire juvénile, il dit :
« Je suis si heureux. Je l'aime. C'est une fille fantastique. »
Et c'est vrai.
A 21 ans, elle vient d'être acceptée pour rejoindre Deah
à l'école dentaire d'UNC.
Elle partageait sa passion du basket et à sa demande,
leur lune de miel a commencé par un match de leur équipe préférée de la NBA,
les Lakers de L.A.
Regardez cette maîtrise.
( Rires )
Je n'oublierai jamais ce moment passé avec lui --
son bonheur sans contraintes.
Mon petit frère, un gamin obsédé par le basket,
était devenu un jeune homme accompli.
Il était premier de sa classe en école dentaire
et, avec Yusor et Razan,
était impliqué dans des projets communautaires locaux et internationaux
pour les sans-abris et les réfugiés.
Ils prévoyaient un voyage de secours dentaire
pour les réfugiés syriens en Turquie.
Razan, à seulement 19 ans,
mettait sa créativité à profit comme étudiante en génie architectural
afin d'aider les autres,
préparant, entre autres, des trousses de soin pour les sans-abris.
Voilà qui ils étaient.
Cette nuit-là,
j'ai pris une grande inspiration, ai regardé Deah et lui ai dit :
« Je n'ai jamais été plus fière de toi que je le suis actuellement. »
Il m'a attirée vers lui,
m'a souhaité bonne nuit.
Sans le réveiller, je suis partie le lendemain
pour retourner à San Francisco.
C'est la dernière fois que je l'ai serré dans mes bras.
Dix jours plus tard, j'étais de garde à l'hôpital de San Francisco
quand j'ai reçu un flot de messages vagues exprimant des condoléances.
Confuse, j'ai appellé mon père qui m'a dit calmement :
« Il y a eu une fusillade à Chapel Hill, le quartier de Deah.
Le quartier est bouclé. C'est tout ce qu'on sait. »
J'ai raccroché et ai cherché sur Google : « fusillade à Chapel Hill ».
Un résultat.
Je cite :
« Trois personnes ont reçu une balle dans la tête,
leur mort a été confirmée sur les lieux. »
Quelque chose en moi savait.
Je me suis levée de ma chaise, me suis effondrée sur le sol de l'hôpital
en hurlant.
J'ai pris le premier vol partant de San Francisco,
abasourdie et désorientée.
Je suis rentrée dans ma maison d'enfance,
me suis effondrée dans les bras de mes parents en pleurant.
Puis j'ai couru dans la chambre de Deah, comme je l'ai fait si souvent,
en le cherchant.
Je n'ai trouvé qu'un vide qui ne sera jamais comblé.
L'enquête et les rapports d'autopsie ont fini par révéler
l'ordre des événements.
Deah rentrait de classe et venait de descendre du bus,
Razan venait dîner, elle était déjà à la maison avec Yusor.
Au début du dîner, quelqu'un a frappé à la porte.
Quand Deah a ouvert,
leur voisin lui a tiré plusieurs fois dessus.
Selon les appels à la police,
les filles hurlaient.
L'homme s'est tourné vers la cuisine et a tiré dans la hanche de Yusor,
l'immobilisant.
Puis il s'est approché par derrière,
a pressé le canon de son arme contre sa tête
et, d'une seule balle, a pulvérisé sa tête.
Puis il s'est tourné vers Razan, qui criait pour sa vie,
et, à la façon d'une exécution, d'une seule balle
à l'arrière de sa tête,
l'a tuée.
En sortant,
il a tiré une dernière fois sur Deah -- une balle dans la bouche --
un total de huit balles :
deux dans la tête,
deux dans la poitrine
et le reste dans ses extrémités.
Deah, Yusor et Razan ont été exécutés
dans un lieu censé être sûr : chez eux.
Durant des mois, cet homme les avait harcelés :
frappant à leur porte,
brandissant son arme à plusieurs occasions.
Son Facebook était inondé de publications anti-religieuses.
Yusor se sentait particulièrement menacée par lui.
Quand elle a emménagé,
il a dit à Yusor et à sa mère qu'il n'aimait pas leur apparence.
La mère de Yusor lui a dit d'être gentille avec le voisin,
qui apprendrait à les connaître vraiment.
Nous sommes tous devenus si insensibles à la haine
que nous n'aurions jamais pu imaginer que cela finirait par de la violence fatale.
L'homme qui a tué mon frère s'est rendu à la police
peu de temps après les meurtres,
disant qu'il avait tué trois gamins,
à la façon d'une exécution,
suite à un conflit de place de parking.
Ce matin-là, la police a émis une déclaration prématurée,
répétant ses allégations sans une remise en question
ou une enquête complémentaire.
En réalité, il n'y a pas eu de conflit pour une place de parking.
Il n'y a pas eu de dispute,
pas d'infraction.
Mais le mal était déjà fait.
Lors d'un cycle médiatique de 24 heures,
les mots « conflit » et « parking » étaient déjà incontournables.
Je me suis assise sur le lit de mon frère et me suis remémorée ses mots,
les mots qu'il m'a donnés si librement et avec tant d'amour :
« Je suis qui je suis grâce à toi. »
C'est ce dont j'ai besoin pour surmonter ma douleur accablante
et m'exprimer.
Les morts dans ma famille ne peuvent être diminuées
à un sujet à peine traité aux infos locales.
Ils ont été tués par leur voisin à cause de leur foi,
à cause d'un morceau de tissu qu'ils ont choisi de porter sur leur tête,
car ils sont étaient visiblement musulmans.
Une partie de ma rage du moment
était que, si les rôles étaient inversés,
qu'un Arabe, un Musulman ou quelqu'un semblant être musulman
avait tué, à la façon d'une exécution, trois étudiants américains blancs
dans leur maison,
comment aurions-nous appelé cela ?
Une attaque terroriste.
Aux États-Unis, quand des hommes blancs commettent des actes violents,
ce sont des loups solitaires, des malades mentaux
ou des gens motivés par un conflit de parking.
Je savais que je devais donner une voix à ma famille
et j'ai fait la seule chose que je savais faire :
j'ai envoyé un message Facebook à tous mes amis journalistes.
Quelques heures plus tard,
au milieu d'une maison tourmentée débordant d'amis et de famille,
notre voisin Neal est venu, s'est assis auprès de mes parents
et a demandé : « Que puis-je faire ? »
Neal avait près de vingt ans d'expérience en journalisme
mais il a dit clairement ne pas être là comme journaliste
mais comme un voisin bienveillant.
Je lui ai demandé ce que nous devrions faire
étant donné le déluge de demandes d'interview.
Il a offert d'organiser une conférence de presse
dans un centre communautaire local.
Même aujourd'hui, je ne sais comment le remercier :
« Dis-moi quand et toutes les chaînes d'information seront présentes. »
Il a fait pour nous ce que nous ne pouvions faire
dans un moment de dévastation.
J'ai rédigé le communiqué de presse,
portant toujours ma blouse de la veille.
Moins de 24h après les meurtres,
je suis interviewée par Anderson Cooper sur CNN.
Le lendemain, les grands journaux --
dont le New York Times, le Chicago Tribune --
ont publié des articles sur Deah, Yusor et Razan,
nous permettant de reconquérir l'histoire
et d'attirer l'attention du public sur la haine anti-musulmans.
Ces jours-ci,
on dirait que l'islamophobie est une forme d'intolérance acceptable.
Nous devons faire avec et garder le sourire.
Les regards mauvais,
la peur palpable quand on prend l'avion,
les fouilles aléatoires dans les aéroports qui arrivent 99 % du temps.
Cela ne s'arrête pas là.
Des politiques tirent des profits politiques et financiers sur notre dos.
Ici, aux États-Unis,
des candidats présidentiels comme Donald Trump,
qui appelle au recensement des musulmans américains
et à l'interdiction d'entrée dans le pays pour les musulmans et réfugiés.
Les crimes de haine augmentent, ce n'est pas anodin,
en marge des cycles d'élections.
Il y a quelques mois, Khalid Jabara,
un Chrétien américain d'origine libanaise
a été tué par son voisin à Oklahoma --
un homme qui l'appelait : « un immonde arabe ».
Cet homme avait été emprisonné pendant 8 mois
après avoir tenté de renverser la mère de Khalid avec sa voiture.
Vous n'avez probablement pas entendu parler de Khalid
car cela n'a pas été évoqué aux infos nationales.
Le moins que nous puissions faire, c'est d'appeler cela
un crime de haine.
Le moins que nous puissions faire, c'est d'en parler
car la violence et la haine ne surgissent pas du néant.
Peu après avoir repris le travail,
- je suis la plus expérimentée -
l'une de mes patientes regarde une de mes collègues,
fait des gestes vers son visage et dit : « San Bernardino »,
en référence à une attaque terroriste.
Je viens de perdre trois membres de ma famille à cause de l'islamophobie,
et porte-parole
sur la gestion de telles micro-agressions,
et pourtant --
silence.
J'étais découragée.
Humiliée.
Quelques jours après, faisant ma ronde,
cette patiente m'a dit :
« Vous tuez les gens à Los Angeles. »
J'ai regardé autour de moi avec espoir.
À nouveau :
silence.
Je réalise encore une fois
que je dois m'exprimer.
Je me suis assise sur son lit, lui ai demandé gentiment :
« Vous ai-je jamais traitée autrement qu'avec respect et gentillesse ?
N'ai-je pas toujours pris soin de vous avec compassion ? »
Elle a baissé les yeux et réalisé son erreur,
devant toute l'équipe,
elle s'est excusée et a dit :
« Je devrais savoir, je suis mexico-américaine.
On me traite tout le temps ainsi. »
Nombre d'entre nous vivent des micro-agressions quotidiennement.
Vous en avez sans doute déjà vécues
que ce soit pour votre race,
votre sexe,
votre sexualité
ou vos croyances religieuses.
Nous avons tous été témoin de quelque chose d'injuste
et n'avons rien dit.
Peut-être que nous ne disposions pas des outils pour répondre sur le moment.
Peut-être que nous ignorions nos propres préjugés implicites.
Nous savons tous que l'intolérance est inacceptable
mais quand nous la voyons,
nous sommes silencieux
car cela nous rend mal à l'aise.
Mais nous engager dans ce malaise
signifie aussi s'engager dans la zone alliée.
Aux États-Unis, il y a plus de 3 millions de musulmans.
Ce n'est qu'1% de la population totale.
Martin Luther King a dit :
« Finalement,
nous ne nous souviendrons pas des mots de nos ennemis
mais du silence de nos amis. »
Qu'est-ce qui a rendu l'alliance de mon voisin si profonde ?
Différentes choses.
C'était un voisin apportant son soutien
mais aussi son expertise et ses ressources professionnelles
quand les circonstances l'ont exigé.
D'autres ont fait de même.
Larycia Hawkins a employé son estrade
de première professeure afro-américaine titulaire à Wheaton College
pour porter un hijab en solidarité
avec les femmes musulmanes faisant face aux discriminations chaque jour.
Cela lui a fait perdre son travail.
En un mois,
elle a rejoint l'université de Virginie
où elle travaille sur le pluralisme, la race, la foi et la culture.
Le co-fondateur de Reddit, Alexis Ohanian,
a montré que tout soutien actif n'a pas à être si sérieux.
Il a soutenu la mission d'une fille musulmane de 15 ans
d'introduire un émoticône avec un hijab.
(Rires)
C'est un geste simple
mais il a un impact subconscient important
pour la normalisation et l'humanisation des musulmans,
leur inclusion dans la communauté, faisant partie d'un « nous »
plutôt qu'être un « autre ».
L'éditeur en chef du magazine Women's Running
a mis la première femme avec une hijab en première page d'un magazine de sport.
Ce sont différents exemples
de personnes mettant à profit leur position et leurs ressources
dans une université, la technologie et les médias,
pour exprimer activement leur soutien.
Quelles ressources et expertise apportez-vous ?
Êtes-vous prêt à vous engager dans votre malaise
et à vous exprimer face à l'intolérance haineuse ?
Serez-vous Neal ?
Beaucoup de voisins sont apparus dans cette histoire.
Vous, dans vos communautés respectives, avez tous un voisin musulman,
un collègue
ou un ami avec qui votre enfant joue à l'école.
Contactez-les.
Faites-leur savoir que vous êtes solidaire avec eux.
Cela peut sembler être peu
mais cela fera une différence.
Rien ne ramènera jamais Deah, Yusor et Razan.
Mais en élevant nos voix collectives,
nous pouvons mettre un terme à la haine.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)